for tuning in with us today my name is
NASA coming from the st. Louis chess
club and scholastic center I'm here with
us today is Oxshott Chandra's he's one
who gave us a recap on his game today
within Final and round three all right
so this was the critical position for my
round three game against Grandmaster
been flying goals so here I'm feeling
better I have a better pawn structure i
canna safer than blacks and my bishop is
better than his night because even
though he has an outpost on Steve clamp
and I start really doing anything on my
bishop had this nice diagram here so
here been played Queen B 6 he maybe
wants to play clean before and then
double his rooks on the e-file and here
i found a really strong idea i played
bishop today so i'm attacking his rook
so he has to play at five now i give
this intermediate check which i think he
missed the point is that if i go back
here she plays it not here so by giving
a check first you know long has that
option because the Queen will hang so he
played king 286 he goes back to GA tai
play Bishop f355 s coming next and it's
totally lost friend so you play key 860
in fact f3 and he played his group to e8
and now I head up on a really strong
idea I played by 55 LED rookie 3 mg for
this idea is from be strong because I'm
totally ripping open the Kings side and
his skin is going to be feeling really
sad and fingers so if you play that text
you for yesterday that it at five
now he page what is he
yeah 97 I took the plunger for late
night of six teenage forecheck we played
not age five so he's managed to protect
his skin for the time being but but why
has a really strong move now if he plays
F takes g 6 h takes g6g one threatening
Queen g5g g six so he has to play some
of tv5 but say this room this is what
I'd seen during the game but I for some
reason didn't go first but ok this one
where Jeff one just kills my ropes
coming down to f/8 and h eight and he's
just going to lose instead I played
something else which wasn't a strong I
played f6 here an idea was good i played
f6 hear my idea was to keep his Kings
caged in the corner and he played now
Queen d8i sorry he should have played
Queen da the game would have continued
then the whites probably still winning
instead he played rock cafe and now he
missed a really nice soft trip to 5 13
Queen g5 check me so if it takes all my
other work to the chief file and you
still can defend the g5 square see if
they Ricky one child I took
she takes that play Ruby g1 he might
have between 3 35 square but I just play
Bishop f3 it was his night and he's
gonna get made it into fuels so here you
resent well thank you for showing that
that what do you think the chances are
in earning unnormal okay i think my
justice should be fairly good but I
don't speculate too much
you